the first question actually goes to sean
um sean i really need to know um the
probably the most important thing i'm
going to ask today uh how did you
get involved as the dad in the taylor
swift music video
that that i have been asked that
question a lot
and i actually called my social media
director slash
cultural guru ryan reynolds and i was
like ryan people keep asking i'm
actually being asked to do like
interviews about it do i explain the
whole convoluted origin story and my
guru social media advisor ryan reynolds
vance city reynolds said
just don't it's cooler if you don't so
i'm actually going to violate my own
maker which is to be verbally
promiscuous
and i'm going to play it
kind of cool i don't often play it
okay um i'll just say this that is that
is that is not an off camera head of
hair that sean levy has over there that
is a uh it should be a front and center
mug right there i'm afraid there might
have been a side letter with t swift
that if the hair was well featured yes i
would come and play who doesn't want to
be in a taylor swift music video i mean
come on yeah right i i just ryan i just
have to ask you as the as the actor of
the group uh did you have any critiques
of sean's performance in his reaction at
the table do you want to give him any
notes for future things
i
actually thought he was fantastic
you know shawn started as an actor so
that's what makes him such a great
director
get into that head
yeah but you know right he's great
perfect flawless as i told you ryan i
was sitting at the table with sadie and
dylan and dylan is telling me some
improvised story and taylor's like
action cut and i remember saying to
dylan i'd have i did not hear a word of
what you were saying all i was thinking
about is why are you doing that with
your hands why are you laughing so
maniacally um it definitely gave me a
taste to be back on camera reminded me
why i do not want it
uh ryan your better half uh
recently directed at taylor swift music
video made me think about you and
directing have you actually thought
about it or is that something that just
doesn't interest you
um i you know it
genuinely doesn't into storytelling
interests me in every way shape or form
producing interests me in every way
shape and form same with performing and
i get to work with guys like sean levy i
don't know why i would uh
try to think i can do that on my own um
that would be idiotic if i could direct
something with sean levy down the road
someday
that would be nice but um no i mean i i
i love the position i'm in i love that i
get to work with folks that i get to
work with and i also just really feel
like
you know
why why why would i deprive myself of
that amazing collaborator you know i
just think that that's so important
um in everything that i do i don't ever
pretend to be a person who's just you
know unilaterally deciding this or that
or you know i just love i love the
creative process of having someone to
bounce something off off of i love the
creative process of trial and error of
of you know ripping something apart and
rebuilding it again it's just that's
that's that's the thing that i'm most
interested and i love doing that with
someone
i i also uh steve we i could take a
deeper dive into this but i really have
to say
obviously ryan has been a famous actor
and a star for a long time but i had
never really uh i've never had an actual
fellow producer alongside me who was as
additive and is as additive to every
step of the process as ryan i think if
i'm not mistaken i mean ryan's produced
like four movies and it's two deadpools
and it's free guy and adam project and
i think that the level of craft the
level of execution in all four of those
and by the way it's also noteworthy that
they're so different from each other but
i never kind of knew that you could have
a fellow producer someone where in
script in casting on set in the edit in
song selection in score in sound mix
these are things where ryan and i have
been very much in lockstep and um kind
of as a duo on free guy and adam project
and um no he's as a filmmaker and so
much more than just as a performer
is the real deal
uh you guys have you guys are really
involved in the in the movie business
and i think from the outside people
think of the movie business in a certain
way what do you think might surprise
people about the actual making of a
movie that they just don't know about
that it's like obstacles you guys have
to deal with all the time that just
isn't talked about i'm just trying to
shine a light on you know trying to
educate people i mean i i would say that
that you know
look there's there's vast differences
between you know a set you might find
yourself on of ours and someone else's i
mean they're all you know they sort of
tend to have their own kind of language
or feel but you know i i it's it's sort
of like running any other business
that's the thing at least i find most
shocking is that it's important and
certainly for sean and i the movies that
we produce together to come in on time
you know
on or under budget and and finish either
on time or early and and you know having
a kind of responsibility and that
position is certainly important to me i
know it's important to sean um
and then you know i think about little
walker scobel who's in adam project with
us who just couldn't believe that there
was more than four people who make a
movie you know i mean like he his first
day on set he just looked like he had
two dinner plates for eyes because he
was expecting that it was going to be
sean and me and maybe a cameraman and
somebody who might you know
have snacks
uh and he's not wrong but there's you
know hundreds of other people that that
go into bacon this cake and um you know
i think that was pretty eye-opening for
him at least i would add maybe the other
thing that people don't don't realize is
every day at every stage
if you're open to ideas that come to you
on the fly
they end up being movie defining
decisions and uh and
so whether it's you're acting a scene
and you're directing a scene and uh
maybe i come up with there's a scene in
our movie where like we're doing the
scene it was pretty good but ryan and i
were both like uh it's pretty good and
then suddenly i said to walker shine the
flashlight in ryan's face
just bug him just like shining the
flashlight in his face and then it led
to
basically the the center piece of the
scene where like ryan steals it out of
the kid's hand he shines in the kid's
face you never know what are going to be
the small little ideas that make
something better and that carries every
day all the way through post-production
yeah and if i could if i could pile on
one more thought to that which is that
you know
i i the thing i i genuinely love the
most about the privilege it is to making
movies is that is is listening to the
movie i mean when you listen to the
movie it will tell you things and if you
sort of are quite ardent about you know
and dogmatic about the script and the
story has to be this you know you you
miss out on a lot of things and it's
sort of it's it's it's expanding on the
same point that sean just made but when
you really sit there and kind of
put your ear to the ground and listen to
the story you're telling it says
all kinds of things that you wouldn't
expect it to say
or tell you and if you listen to those
things magic happens and that's that's
the part that i think keeps me awake at
night and keeps me excited and energized
to do this for as long as i can possibly
do it
uh speaking of the atom project um i'm
so curious how long have you guys been
developing this was this before free
guide during free guy like talk a little
bit about the genesis of this thing well
the script had been developed for like
six or seven years
before it came to ryan and then me so
jonathan tropper uh it was an idea that
some other writers had in sky dance and
developed it for six or seven years with
jonathan tropper and then david ellison
told ryan ryan and i were in
post-production on free guy david said i
have this movie that i think you might
like
and as i recall it ryan he pitched you
the idea and you had a pretty immediate
feeling that oh this could be something
for us right
yeah it was what was odd though was that
again like it's it's it's one of those
weird i don't mean to be too esoteric
but kind of kismet things which is that
shawn and i were both looking for
a story about
that that sort of told the father-son
mother-son
story in a in a strange new light
and we had been actually flirting with
another project which had a kind of
interestingly similar dynamic to my
dynamic with mark ruffalo in the film
who plays my father who's you know
roughly the same age as me and we and
that and we love that wish fulfillment
but we've been flirting with this other
film for a long time it just felt kind
of square peg round hole it wasn't quite
getting there and that's when david
ellison at skydance you know he came
over to my apartment and like you know
that's that never happens i mean david
ellison is pretty
he's as big a big shot as it gets so you
know when he sits down and he's there
it's something that he's very passionate
about and i love that he was so
passionate about this story
um you know you don't find that every
day either in a person who's running a a
huge production company studio like
skydance so uh it but it just it was it
it rung all the bells it was everything
you know and i and i basically went
running to
john uh to either beg him or threaten
him whatever kind of came first or came
to top of mind to do this movie uh
together and uh thankfully he he saw the
same mechanics that i saw that made it
so romantic and beautiful
one of the things about the film that i
think it does so one of the many things
that does so well is it balances all
these different tones it's emotional it
has heart it has great action you know
it it's really hard to pull off what you
guys did can you sort of talk about how
the f did you pull this off in terms of
balancing all these different things you
know i
tone is
i'm the longer i do this job the more i
think well tone is my job
tone is a director's job that is your
job to have some north star instinct
about what the movie should feel like
and i remember actually back when you
and i met steve uh circa real steel the
shooting of real steel and spielberg was
one of the producers and i remember uh
one of the things uh one of the
conversations i had with him i said you
know there's like an infinite number of
shots at every given moment how do you
know the right angle and he said to me
the way you picture it that makes it
right
the way you picture it that's the right
one
and so if there was something about well
okay i guess that's kind of all you have
is your instinct about what is the right
way to do it so for me
tone
free guy is a very specific tone and
it's very different than adam project
and brian and i loved by the way that
our back-to-back movies would be very
different from one another but on adam
project kind of an old-school blend of
spectacle
warmth humor and aspirational wish
fulfillment it's a lot of words it's a
lot of like hands-on faders to go with
like the mixing board analogy
as to where things go up and down that's
instinct and that's kind of the only
skill i have is
the longer i do this job trusting that
trusting that instinct and it's also i
think it's also one of the things i love
about working with sean is that sean has
a very sort of unique perspective on
films when he's directing a film and
he's there on set he's also in that very
moment sitting in the audience
and i feel like that is a superpower
that that cannot be overlooked because
it really allows him a kind of in the
moment a real objective sort of point of
view on what's happening and how this
feels and i like to think i'm sitting
there next to him stealing his popcorn
or whatever you want to say but like i
love that as well and i think it's it's
so important to do that in these moments
particularly in movies like this where
those tones are so important and you you
know you're using the kind of fader
analogy that he used which i love but
that's an equalizer sort of idea to kind
of you know add a little bit more here a
little bit less there and it's uh yeah
that feeling is so important and that's
the thing i always grab on to the most
is is what what is the feeling this
movie is trying to convey what is that
what is that um and i
i love that i mean i loved how free guy
was joy you know and we made that kind
of
particularly in an era that i wouldn't
say would certainly wouldn't uh be
naive enough to say that we're
completely out of yet but it was a
really tough period in history i mean
it's like we're all you know the the
news cycles are just absolutely intense
and it was this this opportunity to tell
a story
in via a film that really just expressed
pure joy and radiated that and i love
that about it and adam project is
similarly expresses a kind of warmth and
nostalgic sort of feeling that is uh
that that are that you know we're films
that we grew up with watching loved you
know amblin movies that you know took us
away
i i feel like so much of the kind of
movie marketplace now
it's like movies are they tend to be one
of two things they tend to be popcorn
escapism
or
emotional weighty thematic
you know a kind of idea based movies and
i'd like to think
and i know my favorite movies
they get they get both they are
unembarrassed about wanting to entertain
and they are
absolutely determined to also make you
feel to also make you connect to themes
that feel relatable and resonant so with
adam project we wanted an old-fashioned
eat your popcorn enjoy the ride kind of
movie but we also believe that if we did
our jobs right
you could connect to feelings in people
that are universal the way we look back
at ourselves the way we forgive our
parents the way we come to appreciate
our parents
uh all of this that's what the movie's
about so to entertain but also to
connect those were like the dual goals
for us on adam project
uh in the film you reference a
lightsaber there's also a nod in the
third act that i won't reveal between
that that happens um i'm just curious
with your relationship after free guy
was it easy to get these things in the
movie or was it still a challenge to be
clear steve there is no lightsaber in
the movie but
you say lightsaber we do and when it
came time to design that device that is
actually called a magsil i don't know
why we can ask jonathan dropper it's
like m-a-g capital c-y-l
magnetic cylinder i don't know um
i had to design it basically fear of
lawsuit
led me to multiple design iterations so
that it was never just going to be a
shafty beam of light uh especially a
double-sided thing like darth maul used
to wield um so no we didn't need
permission this time because we're
saving those cards for when we really
need it on free guy movies
yeah sure
and also also the kid you know the kid
really does sort of react to it the way
any kid would which is like is that a
lightsaber you know my character says
it's not a lightsaber and he he's just
convinced it is which i sort of love
that as a bit of a runner
uh walker is so fantastic in this movie
and he i absolutely believe he's a young
ryan he has no professional acting
experience in terms of this is his first
movie how did you both know this was the
kid
and because he really has to deliver a
performance or this movie is not going
to work i mean he has to deliver a
performance
and he has to be believably young ryan
so those are different things right he
needed the emotional heft and dimension
to deliver pretty important emotional
content but he also needed to be a
freaking smart ass
punk who probably got beat up a lot
because of the mouth on them and uh i
have no knowledge about that being a
part of your history ryan but it
wouldn't shock me uh to hear that maybe
it was or certainly that your mouth was
a weapon
i have three old i have three older
brothers sean it was all i had
so yeah so it helped that walker is both
inherently super talented but he also
and we didn't know this when we hired
him he's obsessed with deadpool he has
watched both deadpool movies
on like inappropriate
repeat
such that he can now recite them i i one
of the things though about the way
walker talks is a lot of the dialogue he
says i feel like it's ryan talking so
i'm curious ryan how much is what he's
saying
like improvised on the moment how much
is that all scripted in advance because
it clearly has your fingerprints all
over this
oh he's walker's amazing i mean we i'd
fire off ten alts to any given joke or
moment you know also we're always
looking for it too again sean and i both
were sitting there listening to this
movie so there's you know there's
there's all sorts of things that come
about out of nowhere um and and work in
in surprising ways uh but but not the
least of which is you you could throw
that kid anything and he'll deliver it
perfectly i mean it was just
unbelievable he it really felt like he
felt like a much more um
extroverted version of me as a kid i was
much more shy than he was but but he he
really could turn that on but actually
walker in real life is quite shy you
know walker in real life is a kid that
you know i think lives in his head a
little bit and and you know
that i'm not saying that that's an easy
thing necessarily but i know it it gives
him a kind of dimension and depth that
you don't find with a lot of kids at 12
years old and he he really he really
delivered that i really felt like his
mouth and the smart alec or smart ass
kind of behavior that he has was similar
to mine which was a you know it was a
maladaptive coping mechanism
it was a it was a way to kind of pave
over you know uh other [ __ ] going on
that i i didn't really want to
acknowledge as a young kid and as a
young man so
you guys have made uh you guys have
worked all over the place in hollywood
uh sean you have a you both of you have
worked for netflix before can you sort
of talk about what is it is there any
difference to making a film at netflix
versus the other studios
or other streamers um i'm just curious
about the dynamic behind the scenes
well i will this was my first movie for
a streamer i've not made i mean i've
made a lot of television starting with
stranger things for netflix and i will
say that i found this movie similar to
my experience on shadow and bone and
stranger things and um in that
they
really do tend to trust the people they
hired so
much like on the shows i do i would say
on on adam project
you know we got the support we got input
when they thought something was you know
worthy of adjustment they're not going
to be shy about giving you notes but
they don't feel like they're in your
business and you know but i do but i
don't want to so there is a lot of
creative autonomy but i don't want to
default to this narrative that oh well
the legacy studios are up in your
business all the time and netflix let
you run run free the truth is that
um as we learned with free guy if you at
the stage of career that ryan and i have
worked really hard to achieve
there's a bedrock of trust that we know
how to make something responsibly and in
a way that audiences will like and if
you have that trust from the studio as
we did from netflix as we did from
disney and fox and free guy you tend to
be get
you're left mostly alone um so
that's that's also you know that i think
that's also one one sort of hack that i
think both sean and i share this in
common which is that there's not a lot
of layers with us like you know with
respect to our relationships at the
legacy studios and the streamers they're
when you're getting in touch with us
there isn't like i got to go through a
you know an agent or a manager a lawyer
or a publicist it's just just they we
have a open line of communication that
that really kind of fosters uh certainly
um um accountability uh which is which
is you know a huge a huge part of why
we're able to kind of i think make some
of these movies and tell these stories
um because that does like sean mentioned
sort of create a foundation of trust but
also you know
one thing i love about netflix and you
know is is their real commitment to
telling original stories i mean we get
to you know this doesn't happen every
day a movie like this i need to make
this which isn't based on anything you
know and and we felt so spoiled that we
got to make free guy at disney you know
which was another totally original kind
of new idea and a new concept and um and
they they embraced it so wholeheartedly
but netflix is that's that's what they
do over here and it's pretty it's pretty
awesome i gotta say
uh you got did you test screen the atom
project and what did you learn from
those test screenings that impacted the
finished film
we did test atom project twice just as
we tested free guy twice
um
the test screenings were extremely
encouraging
i had not realized how much of a comedy
the movie
plays as until i heard it with the test
audience the numbers were very strong as
they had been on free guy we learned
you know what's really interesting
there's a scene that a lot of people
talk about it's a scene in a bar with
ryan and jen garner and they are we're
going to get there
okay
you know what was a what was a shocker
when you do a test screening on a
hollywood movie you get your scores but
they also get to rank you're talking
about 300 strangers rank their favorite
scenes or least favorite scenes and you
look at those charts and you look for
trends
that bar scene a drama scene a drama
dialogue scene every time top two scenes
that doesn't happen with drama scenes
you know it is not rushed there's no
action there's not a joke it's just
feeling and that was where i realized oh
you know what we can trust the audience
here because they're going to connect to
the emotional part of the movie as much
as the action and the comedy so that was
very affirming
and that i learned in test screenings
did you guys take out are there a lot of
deleted scenes in the movie um i was
just asked which ones i wanted to uh
approve to put in the world and there
were only um i think we took out four in
total
um and two of them are are good enough
that i'm going to put them out i don't
even know where where does it go
anywhere
i was going to say what one should be a
collider exclusive and uh we will be
happy to run it for you
well then i'll tell you this if they'll
let us do that my our personal favorite
is there's a scene between ruffalo and
ryan where basically the father says to
the son
you know look somewhere between the
villain that you think i am and the hero
that young you thinks i am
there's the real guy i'm neither and i'm
just a guy doing the best i can
and it is so i think honest and true
about the way we see our dads or need to
see our dads
and um it's a lovely scene but to ryan's
point great scene as a standalone but
that's not enough of a reason to keep it
in a cut the movie needs to tell you
what it wants and as we watch the flow
of the narrative it was like the body
rejected that organ in a weird way i'm
coming up with crazy metaphors today
guys
sound mixing boards surgery and rejected
organs
but father that that scene with rough
flow and ryan that's that's one of my
favorites and uh i'm glad we'll somehow
see it maybe on collider
you